hey how's it going guys my name is
Bearpaw and welcome to blood-borne I am
so [ __ ] excited for this game if
anyone asked me what my what my
favourite game is right now I would
definitely say Dark Souls and this is
made by the same creators my body is so
ready I don't even feel like talking
let's just go I like my pants
oh hi there friend just gonna go past no
big deal
oh my god
oh my god yep ah no no no don't [ __ ]
left Oh God
well then that in Nevada spirit does it
in are they giving me stuff
the messengers offer you a firearm
thanks friends well [ __ ] you and your
bait that's 400 I love it all all on
come on
yes amazing let's go this way
Oh God you thought you could [ __ ] it up
with me ah you could hey
yes the ragdolls are back i miss them so
much
boy mate mmm Oh God
hey Barney you look good tonight I'm a
babe you ugly son of a fate
hey Berta that's a nice skirt Berta yeah
that's right I'm talking to you baby
come on let's take ah ah you son of a
[ __ ] they always hide no you sniff stop
stop stop don't [ __ ] flame no this is
impossible
how did I die
oh my god almost died again no not today
ah
oh yes [ __ ] yo ah suck my ass
goddamnit I get way too much into this
Oh
kite is a cha
ah nay you crimp the MAME it is hit yeah
blah blah one tiny little mistake and I
play so well and this is snot hey I'm
done already
so look at this look at this look at
this coupons free coupon what are you
doing can't they see I'm busy
how did he hit me I dodge don't you dare
hit me if I die I'm gonna kill you I'm
gonna kill you I'm alive I'm alive
it's a goddamn here yes ah oh my oh my
god no what are you doing not happening
not I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not
number nap ah what the [ __ ] is that what
the [ __ ] are you where do you come where
did he come from where where where where
where no now there is no solely in order
to build our nation we must all exceed
our own expectations Oh
have you ever had an ass in your ass
want to have a good time wanna have a
good time baby hmm
you good time oh my god I was [ __ ]
close I will cry tears of sadness I will
I will literally cry if we die now just
gonna go down here do bad rebels don't
oh my god no no
where's the [ __ ] bonfire
whereas I ah now you Stefani tequila may
English new LeMay better better better
better better love elephants
how does that feel get fisted
what
what killed me what killed me I don't
eat been talking no yes listen listen
oh my god what the [ __ ] are you what the
[ __ ] I can't fight a beast now can't
even fight my mom can't even beat the
first what the [ __ ] are you doing here
now so done with you so down with
everyone shut up ah [ __ ] hate you you
hairy [ __ ] you sound like a
[ __ ] dead
I'm gonna pick this up ah ah what is he
doing
stop stop your herring no one likes you
ever heard of waxing geez ah no this is
not the day when I die I think what are
you doing picking me up don't throw me
what did I say hairy [ __ ]
great pass battle
and on attend would never hair again
oh my god I'm killing handicaps this is
a new win for me what I just did but
[ __ ] it life's handing you lemons
I'd play blood-borne where am I [ __ ]
bird oh my god what the [ __ ] is that
hwadam indiana jones indiana jones the
soul of indiana jones just saved my life
Thank You Indiana Jones I love you too
bad you missed and kill all your friends
breasts we're back
I lost my save file didn't take long to
replay it's very late now it's it's 3:00
in the morning I just got back and I'm
like I need to play more I'm so I love
I'm so into this game I need to finish
this first boss so we're going to do
that but I'm not going to yell like an
idiot
he's known as wrong what are you kidding
me
I went along side
I'm so focused
a Frick late night
that oh my god and I went
so good hmm oh this makes me so happy
you bros have no idea I really wanted to
beat everyone boss today so we're just
gonna we're just going to end it there
but if you want to do a series of these
I would love to so please leave a like
share with your grandma share your
support I really appreciate it and then
we can keep this going and I will go
insane like last time but it will be an
amazing time they was watching as always
stay awesome